this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond register for free at
dndbeyond.com to start your adventure
[Music]
it's time once again for the oscars the
award show that no one watches honoring
the films barely anyone has seen but in
a year where theaters were still shut
down there's have a chance you streamed
one of these before switching over to
squid game so in case you need a primer
here are the honest trailers for this
year's 10 best picture nominees
[Music]
from the one director your grandma can
name comes one musical even your bros
have heard of west side story bro what
bro based on that one shakespeare plot
you know and this sweeping epic about
race class gender and violence that
remains as relevant today as it was 60
years ago which is kind of depressing
when you think about it how many times
do i gotta tell you bernardo i don't
speak spanish
but it's got a cast packed with breakout
stars like arianna dubose rachel zegler
ansel antoine and the guy who plays riff
wow he was great let's not have
off-screen reality in the way of
enjoying this great musical i mean right
you have grown into rapists
ah
tonio and juliet
for years when hollywood needed a shy
pale boy with a goofy name they called
benedict cumberbatch but when a shire
paler more goofily named actor arrives
on his ranch benny will transform into
the most grizzled cow poke since bronco
henry bronco henry bronco henry uncle
henry bronco henry as you watch things
go from strange to weird in this
psychosexual tug-of-war between uncle
and nephew full of new dudes having fun
woods porn and
balls being removed
with a shocking twist that sometimes the
insecure homophobic bullies are actually
gay themselves was this really a
surprise though i mean i call this as
soon as he fingered that flower bronco
henry himself taught me how to decode a
metaphor not there that's a butthole
who let the dogs out
step right up folks for the most
incredible mind-blowing cinematic
sensation of 2021 an entire film made
only from the colors orange and blue
starring the incredible cooper kid a 50
year old actor who appears to everyone
like a much younger man young look
usually for a boy it's the old it's not
that my boy now in the past you may have
seen guillermo del toro make fish
friends phantoms and fire fiends
friendly fine and even [ __ ] but
right here on this very screen he's
about to take on his greatest challenge
yet he's going to humanize a carny
that's right folks with a low low price
of one hbo max subscription or hulu if
you prefer my good sir watch these
dangerous drifters display dozens of
deeds of devotion and decency i'll give
you five
plus a nice hot meal steak and eggs on
me you can sleep there tonight stay out
of the rain you need work say maybe you
can hawk for me would a steady job be of
interest to you coffee and cakes
dry place to sleep
shop now and then what do you say so
grab two bits and spin around in a
circle for this landmark in on-screen
hobo representation and hey till my old
epic voice man sent you
exit through the griff top
from a bunch of japanese people who know
way more about western literature and
philosophy than you do
comes a film that's about the importance
of social connection the limits of human
language and perseverance in the face of
unspeakable tragedy but like
metaphorically on screen it's mostly
shots of a guy listening to a tape of
his dead wife in the backseat of a sob
am i right lots to think about
would wolverine's healing factor reverse
his circumcision
sob story
venus williams was the number one ranked
tennis player in the world serena is one
of the greatest of all time but what was
their dad like weird question but okay
we'll roll with it meet richard williams
he may talk like mike tyson nothing is
impossible but he sure doesn't fight
like him
and he stopped beating on me he knocked
me down his friends come over they all
start stomping on me beating them will
smith plays a man who would do anything
to see his girl succeed even if it meant
selling the extra fabric from his shorts
as he treats his own daughters like
lotto tickets and or child soldiers he
will show him how dangerous you are yes
got to have a plan for every day
elsewhere
girls spell civilization
in this inspiring story of how venus
serena their mother and the ned flanders
of tennis came together to succeed
despite having a grandstanding
narcissist dad who makes everything
about him that's [ __ ] it's about you
gotta ruin everybody else's day
served at a compton
[Music]
we did the honest trailer we sung its
praises from the rooftops now with
nothing new to say about dune
we'll just mention that we've been
catching up on euphoria and oh man do we
have thoughts on the way
daru
sandstorm
if you see one portrait of a director's
hazily remembered childhood make it
licorice pizza as paul thomas anderson
writes a love letter to the san fernando
valley
no not that one
not that one either okay they're all set
in the valley we get it in this love
story about a middle-aged man in a 15
year old's body
and a teenage girl in a 25 year old's
body
so i guess it's fine that they hook up
in the end right it's not any worse than
blank jack why don't you give me a call
and say about 10 years
once upon a time in north hollywood
if you see two portraits of a director's
hastily remembered childhood make the
other one belfast kenneth branagh tries
to have it all combining the whimsy of
his youth with the grim backdrop of
ethno-religious violence the fifty
shades of grey guy with actually good
acting
who knew and the earnest corny vibe of a
musical with only one actual song and
dancing in a combination that almost
works there's just something a bit off
can't quite put my finger on it just
found it unsettling for some reason
don't look back
cats they did it in cats how would you
address
a cat
big troubles in northern ireland
from the studio who was too late to
acquire any franchises that you've heard
of comes a film that shows off what
apple tv does best stories about people
with one more sense than the rest of
their families and stories about
inspiring mustache coaches who will
never quit on you in this coming of age
tale of a girl trapped with the horniest
friends and family imaginable i hooked
up with tiny fingers
is that your mom
that teaches us all an important lesson
about the deaf community
how to say my nuts are on fire in asl
seinfeld
in a world where everyone is too
distracted or lazy to do anything about
the environment one netflix movie will
reassure you it's only the dumb people's
fault that things are bad not you you're
smart enough to be watching this netflix
movie you get it in a two-hour metaphor
for climate change that takes aim at
everyone from daytime tv host there is a
comment but it's a good thing to pop
stars you guys discovered a comet i have
a tattoo of a shooting star in my back
to the president's dumb kid there are
you the working class
us the cool rich without alluding to oh
i don't know the oil industry but hey
what do i know i'm not famous
smarmageddon
starring the hyper specific best picture
genres these nominees fall into
the depressing secret gay cowboy love
affair the lighthearted kids point of
view on growing up in a war zone a
musician rebelling from then ultimately
embracing the deaf community widowers
and cars driving silently is abuse the
price of being really good at something
paul thomas anderson films about very
awkward relationships remake of a
musical about star-crossed lovers where
the dude dies at the end
star wars
movie starring bradley cooper and an
obvious prosthetic baby
and movies with such a ham-fisted
unsettled message that we'll all be
extremely embarrassed about it winning
in five years if not right now
the oscars 2022
why can't they just give all the oscars
to spider-man clearly that's the world's
favorite movie this year that's what the
money is for right right right
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond battle for beyond
subscribe to ddb's youtube to join the
battle
when your voice is this epic you don't
need an oscar nomination but an emmy
would be nice
i'm gonna make an offer he can't refuse
catchphrase